Albert Brewer of the mm QB is here on
the show good to see you on good to see
you too right ask him let's go straight
into it let's jump in headfirst with
Albert Brewer Brockman all right here we
go who should be the Jag starting
quarterback Blake bortles Chad Henne
Colin Kaepernick I think Chad Henne is
the safe choice right now and I know
that that sounds crazy but if you watch
their first two preseason games and look
at how Blake looks running the offense
versus how Chad Henne looks running the
offense and I think Tom Coughlin and
Doug Marrone could be okay with Chad
Henne running the offense because again
I think this year is about evaluation
for them and figuring out where they are
and figuring out what they have in cam
Robinson and modern floor net and Allen
Robinson and all those guys the high-end
potential though if you want the higher
ceiling its Colin Kaepernick I mean it's
just I like I think there's we said this
a second ago the infrastructure is there
I mean Doug Marrone and Nathaniel
Hackett ran in Buffalo for EJ Manuel
read-option elements and so you can add
those elements into the office very
easily they're already there for him and
he creates a different kind of threat on
a week to week basis so if you're
looking to tread water this year the
answer is Chad Henne if you're looking
say how can we create a threat how can
we do something a little different how
can we put ourselves in a position where
maybe in a weak division maybe we're in
it in December then I think it's
probably cap it's not a weak division
though I think the Titans ending and
infections are our good teams and I
think the Titans are going to take a
step forward and even throw their hat
into a buy one for this year but how can
they tread water or want to see what
they have when they've already picked up
the option for next year on on board of
law and if this is like an rg3 situation
what part of it like was the rg3
situation - which refers they picked up
his odd right before knowing that so
knowing that maybe he wasn't the
quarterback of the future and they just
sat him to make sure he didn't get hurt
and the logistics of this for the people
out there who don't understand is that
when you pick up that option it's not
fully guarantee but it is injury
guaranteed right so if that player can't
pass a physical in march you're on this
then you're on the hook for it and
that's 19 million
dollars they'd be on the hook for what
you and so look that's the part of it
where you look at it now and look if
there was a glimmer the plank was going
to be the long-term answer there I don't
blame them for hanging on to him because
you want to gather more information
right like the worst thing is you let
him go and then he goes and flourishes
somewhere else so I understand like Tom
Coughlin came in he hadn't really worked
with the kid right Doug Marrone is the
new head coach you have to make that
decision in May you haven't seen them in
OTAs yet you haven't seen the minicamp
yet you haven't seen them in training
camp so I understand wanting to gather
more information but now if what we saw
last night continues over the next two
weeks now you got to be protecting
yourself now you got to be worried about
being on the hook for that in 2018 and
look you know I think what's really
interesting about this is Tom Coughlin
loved deshaun Watson and that's what
could haunt them here is if Watson goes
and becomes a star in Houston and I
think why number four Nets going to be
dynamite but a running backs running
back if Shawn Watson winds up being what
some people think he's going to be in
Houston Jacksonville could look at
themselves two three years down line and
be kicking themselves in saying we hang
hung on to Blake bortles a year and if
that causes us to pass on Watts Albury
or the mmq be here in the studio so just
walk me through and everybody who's
listening and watching the the timeline
of it so they decided on bortles to pick
up his option next year after the draft
rights they passed on deshaun Watson I
took Leonard fournette with the 4th
overall selection right up deshaun
Watson who was sitting there every
quarterback not named drew Biscay was
sitting there when they went on the
clock right they had the pick of all the
quarterbacks may second I think it was
they picked the eye and they can tell
bortles next year thanks for the
memories without owing him that 18
million dollars if he is a healthy
individual which again Washington did
with rg3 to make sure that he was held
right they stay identical rg3 had two
injury history and Blake doesn't have
quite the injury true and he's and and I
mean Blake bortles is a much bigger
sturdier individual the you know body
wise than playing for al is less so well
and then you look at Ryan Mallett
what are the Ravens going to do here
what are you hearing about Joe Flacco
what I'm hearing about Joe Flacco but
when they made the decision to shut him
down in camp it was this is a week at a
time so we're going to give it one week
and then we're going to reassess and
look I think that there's a recognition
here he's 32 years old he's got a back
issue like even if this is as minor as
they're saying it is those types of
things don't go away especially with
older players especially with big
players a big physically big guys a guy
who's six foot six those types of things
can recur and so I think this is this is
one of those things where it's like on
the on the surface can look minor
because maybe he will be out I'm going
to assume he's going to be out there
week one but it's something you've got
to monitor and take care of you know
it's one of those injuries that can pop
back up at inopportune time and I think
that that's why they're being so
cautious with it so how does this play
out
you think flat goes under Center week
one attention at E no with no preseason
of action of which they've said that
he's not going to play in the preseason
and I think that they feel like you know
in this situation at least there's not
he doesn't need it you know he's been
there for what this is 10th year 10th
year in Baltimore so he doesn't need the
reps and they can replicate it in
practice that's the way that they feel
and it's not worth putting him out there
he takes a hit the wrong way now all of
a sudden he's out sure well that meant
look that makes sense the only thing
that I'm wondering is that is mallet the
viable backup here right it's only an
issue because a Kaepernick well of
course because there's somebody else
sitting out there you want to talk about
the infrastructure that's available to
to a guy who's currently not with the
team to have to walk in last minute and
get up to speed you talked about how
there is a a coach and a coordinator in
Jacksonville who has run a similar
system you know what Kaepernick is
you've got the offensive coordinator who
ran the system when Kaepernick was the
man writing San Francisco currently
sitting there and the interesting thing
about the about the situation in
Baltimore normally the job of backup
quarterback is different than the job of
starting quarterback right and most of
them fall into one of two
gouri's you have either a guy who's the
next guy and that's what Sandra Biscay
mahomes
right but you have the backup who's the
next guy and then you have the backup
who's a resource to the starter most
guys fit into one or two categories and
that's Derrick Anderson for Cam Newton
you know kam Derrick Anderson doesn't
need to take any of Cam Newton's reps
during the week Derrick Anderson is
going to be a second set of eyes for Cam
Newton so the Panthers decide okay it's
more valuable for us to have a resource
for the starter there then have a guy
who can maybe go out win ten games and
what will probably be a lost season if
our starter goes down anyway the
interesting thing about mallet he
doesn't fit into either of those
categories he's not a resource for Joe
Flacco and he's not the next guy and so
that's what's interesting about it
because I think if you don't have either
well now at least have somebody can
create a threat and we talked about that
with Jacksonville how can you create a
threat if Jill Flacco is not available
Colin Kaepernick can create a threat for
you Albert Brewer here in the Rich Eisen
show studio you're here in Los Angeles
because if I'm not mistaken you have
seen the Rams right your visitors Rams
Chargers yep um USC Trojans yep okay you
also have over the last couple of days
interviewed de maras smithing of the
NFLPA if I won't hit all those things
with you when we come back okay okay
Albert Brewer is here in studio we're
back in 60 seconds to hit on that and
more and if you're on hold at 844 204
rich we will take your phone calls don't
go anywhere we're back with Albert Pryor
with Michael Lombardo on deck and Chris
long in the hole here on the Rich Eisen
show welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
al abrir of the mmq V is here in studio
Aziz visiting all the football
highlights that Los Angeles now has to
offer with two college teams and two NFL
teams and in between all of that Albert
you interviewed Amara Smith of the FL
Players Association the e Ezekiel
Elliott suspension appeal hearing is 12
days from today with Harold Henderson
being the designated appeal judge if you
will on behalf of the NFL and the back
and forth between the NFL and the NFL PA
that we I mean that's it speak nastiness
right yet what
where is this coming from Albert me
night as you can tell I think it's been
brewing you know and it's just it's the
general distrust and you know I know the
quote there's a pop twas Dee saying it's
a virtual certainty and I think that
there will be labor so yeah there'll be
a labor stop it like a work stoppage of
some sort in 2021 and I'm with him on
that
I mean 2017 I don't know if it's going
to cost him well think about this though
the last six years if anything happened
the last six years to make you think
that the next four years going to be any
different well and things are markedly
worse surely we're in 2008 2009 2010 if
you remember but the relationship
between Roger and the players wasn't bad
before 2011 in fact there are guys who
are disciplined Ben Roethlisberger
Michael Vick Pacman Jones who built
great relationships with Roger
after being disciplined with him right
like they literally were rehabilitating
guys and now you look at the
relationship between the players and the
Commissioner and the players and a
league no one trusts anyone
they've gone to court several times the
Union thinks that the league has
ulterior motives to everything that they
do the league doesn't trust the Union at
all and it's I don't know where the
turning point come no unless there's
some sort of change in leadership unless
there's some sort of change in
leadership on either side on either side
I like but I just the way it's presently
constituted it looks worse than it did
in oh eight oh nine and ten and we knew
that lockout was coming right we knew
way ahead of time that that was coming
and if things are worse now than they
were then I don't know how you expect it
to forever so this latest blow up is
over a player suspension again yep and
the question is is when push does come
to shove in 2021 will the players want
to have a labor stoppage over the
subject of player discipline which only
affects a small percentage of players
it's not as if yeah the the inbox of the
NFL is filled with hundreds fifty
percent of players being suspended
that's not even close to the case yeah
and I wonder I
in your right and also notice also
notice to that the letter that Ezekiel
Elliott received from the NFL was not
written by Roger Goodell right that
Roger Goodell was not in the room during
these interviews with Ezekiel Elliott
and is it his designated appeal a
hearing officer is not himself right so
he is totally divested himself one would
one would think just on its face it's
not as if he's just absentee on this I'm
sure he's yeah there you go yeah right I
mean so so why would speaking to de
maras Smith did you sense that he he is
what angry upset over Ezekiel Eliot's
the handling of this case what the
league said about the Players
Association this week well I think that
well certainly I think the accusation
that the league made was a serious one I
mean they're saying that their victim
shaming in a domestic violence case I
mean look if that's not true it's a
pretty crappy thing to do if it is true
you know then it is what it is I the
relations I mean like you you you watch
you watch the way that D is kind of
handled this stuff more recently and you
can see that there's a major distrust
there and he said during the interview
like I like Roger which was but you know
like you can tell they don't trust each
other and his problem was again with the
process and how the Zeek investigation
took as long as it did that it took over
a year and that they feel like they're
kind of making up the rules as they go
and I didn't be issue here I mean look I
think the Cowboys the league I think
everyone would agree that Zeek needed a
wake-up call right
I didn't the problem with it is that it
was under the heading of domestic
violence and the question was whether or
not they really got him on that
particular case and in sending a message
to the player it came under that heading
and look if Zeke did it Zeke was guilty
of what they're claiming he's guilty of
and he's now lying about it he deserves
more than 6 games right but if he didn't
do it and this is just a way of sending
a wake-up call that's a scarlet what
letter that he's going to have to wear
that's going to be very difficult to
find it's going to be difficult to get
out from underneath that label for last
question on this is what is Jerry
thinking what's he going to do is he
going to sue the league because he
hasn't said a word and even he said four
different times when asked for a word
when he was speaking publicly last hey
I'm not prepared to talk about this yet
yeah I mean I don't think he I don't
think he's gonna sue the league I mean I
think some of it is some of it his
grandstanding to some degree and what I
always say be no I I know Peter wrote
earlier in the week that you know like
now he's crossed craft and he crossed
Jones and he crossed I mean like there's
been a lot of these where powerful
owners have been in the crosshairs of
Rogers discipline
I always just looked back to why each
Commissioner was in place in the first
place right go back to Pete Rozelle it
was about promoting the game to a higher
PR guy Paul Tagliabue it was during the
80s when there were all the labor
problems we hire lawyer Roger Goodell
was hired at a time when the league
wanted to grow and it had to find new
ways to grow the revenue I think until
Roger fails to do what he was hired to
do he's fine they may get annoyed they
may get angry they may be furious
like Jerry was but I don't think until
he fit until that money train stops
rolling bright I don't think he's truly
and and people I guess it gets lost
amongst all the disciplinary actions
that the Commissioner has taken that he
was he's kind of the first CEO
commissioner of a major sports league
like this this you know country has seen
right and when he got in there it was
when Adam Jones had the Vegas incident
right and Henry Chris Henry of
Cincinnati his incident and he came in
and first thing he had to do was deal
with that and now he's been the
discipline law and order commissioner
ever since I do want to talk some
football in a few minutes I have left
with you Albert Breer um seeing what
what are you taking out of your visit
here to Southern California you saw Sam
Donald yes Yeah right with USC right and
what would you would you leave with him
price I mean he's an impressive kid I
didn't watch him practice but I was over
when we got to visit with him for a
while we're doing a bigger project with
North Turner his first year out of
football and we're going around and
seeing different people who you know
he's going and sitting down talking with
and kind of you know like this is like
what North has to get back to the game
so Norris visited us
so we were we were over there with with
Sam Donald and I thought was so
interesting
he saw us with Shawn McVeigh to which I
thought you know that that's a different
a different job but interesting for the
same reason is Sam jumped into it he
immediately started asking north
questions hey what did Phillip do what
did Drew do how can I be better it's
really interesting because you see this
kid who is in who's a Heisman candidate
who is a huge star in a big market and
potentially the number one pick in the
draft and the first thing that he thinks
of is I've got this guy who coached for
42 years in front of me and I'm going to
get something out of this conversation
and I think it's it's sort of like a man
and brady thing you know like that that
quality now that doesn't mean he's going
to be manning a brain oh no but at least
he's he knows what he doesn't know or
knows that he should know more than what
he thinks he already knows if that makes
any and I thought it was interesting
seeing him with I saw the same thing
with Sean McVeigh you know Sean McVeigh
who's 31 years old a head coach in the
NFL has every reason to kind of maybe be
a little insecure because he's younger
and wants to project that he knows
everything and that he's comfortable and
ready for the job Sean McVeigh spent 45
minutes asking North Karen hey on the
flight back from the combine I was
sitting across the aisle from him and he
was sitting next to Jack Del Rio and he
talked del rio's ear off for the
four-hour flight asking questions about
training camp and schedules and moments
and he walked away from it and he said
Nora I gotta go write a bunch of this
stuff down but what the Rams have done
on that offense right with Sammy Watkins
joining and obviously he's got a chip on
his shoulder with something to prove
tavon Austin everybody's still waiting
firm have that first round top of the
draft talent yet Cooper Cup which
everybody is raving about and Gurley
ready for a bounce-back season and
McVeigh at the controls it's all about
the triggerman isn't it it's going to be
interesting because you know now and
what I think Shawn did really well and
look this goes back to when he was with
Kyle Shanahan and what they did the
first year with RG three you know what
Shawn did was he put Kirk in a
tremendous position to succeed in
Washington in the last couple of years
and so I think for the last three months
it's been okay I had to figure out what
he does well and then we're going to
start with something basic and we're
going to work out from there and
look I don't think he's going to put
Jared Goff in bad situations I don't
think Jared Goff is gonna be standing
back there you know taking 15 to 20 hits
in the game they're going to do things
to take advantage of his strengths and I
mean luck even bringing in a guy like
Whitworth who was so valuable in
Cincinnati who was like the chief of
police in that locker room and we know
with the strong personalities in
Cincinnati how challenging that could be
Whitworth is a huge addition for them
what about Aaron Donald we're going to
see him back before the season I think
we'll see him back I think he'll be back
before the season
okay so what's the holdup here isn't it
I mean he sort of he wants to be the
highest-paid guy on the defensive side
of the ball in football and he's asking
for it two years ahead of time and
that's a complex or a mishap the Rams
what any team would say in the situation
is well one more you can sit here for
the fourth year and we can hold on to
you for the fifth year with the option
and then we can actually tag you the
sixth year and so if we're going to do
something for you early and I think they
do want to do something for him early
well then we need a little give back the
good news is I don't sense any acrimony
here like I think that this is okay look
I think both sides recognize that it's
business whether or not they can come to
an agreement before week one I don't
know but I think that he'll be out there
we are before I let you go Albert who
wins Super Bowl who goes to Super Bowl
fifty one who are you thinking you
remember a circumstance where II D it
keep it for a circumstance where that
Super Bowl champion did as much as the
Patriots did this offseason though I
mean think about this Brandon cooks
Stephon Gilmore eely eely right like and
I who knows if we're gonna get out of a
lead Wayne Allen and and they're adding
back the second-best player on their
team Rob Gronkowski wasn't there in
December January February do you have
news on this front though yeah Derek
rivers torn ACL yesterday in practice
he's out for the year their top their
top draft choice defensive end right so
that's unfortunate I don't mean that
that is that is if there is a little
something there is if there's one
weakness in us on that team that's like
you know that's her I mean as rushing
the passer right so there might be a
little something there but I don't ski
their way to the quarterback
I think I'll figure sagging on with that
well before they have bring Rob Ning
kovitch back maybe while the calls
Dwight Freeney those names are being
thrown out this month yeah I mean with
the secondary they and look the other
rookie they have da trick lies was
actually a head of rivers anyway but
with the secondary they have they're
going to be able to do a lot of things
upfront plus they'll probably be playing
with a lead a lot and I think free would
be perfect
free knees got a lot of left in the tank
he's a smart veteran someone who I'm
sure Belichick respects immensely and
plus personally he bring his Yankee hat
up there he'll be fantastic Kevin Brady
can wear their yeah yes I guess we
established I don't know buddy a browser
warning at uses sue again bringing from
son automatically the ink I get it
that's okay team and Brady can rock the
Yankee good to see you all but if he got
it check out out the mm QB for Albert's
interview with DeMars Smith and also the
future peace on North turn which I'm
happy to have the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show up follow
all the information you see right here
on the Rich Eisen show